you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played at the 45th
United States Open this was held in
Boston Massachusetts in 1944 on the
white end Samuel Reshevsky chess prodigy
learned the game at the age of four was
already conducting simultaneous chess
exhibitions by the age of eight he is a
six-time United States chess champion
and has defeated several world champions
Lasker Karpov and nine others his
opponent I don't have nearly as much to
share about Arnaldo vasconcelos he did
finish sixth in this particular event
among 18 formidable opponents of the few
games that are out there of his one of
them includes him beating a nine time
state champion the state champion of
Maine and it's my impression from the
games I viewed of his that he is around
a master level player this is just my
opinion but I wanted to give you some
sense of the players that are on board
here so as the title suggests we have
fireworks on board in the French defense
and in this one we're working with the
advanced variation not so commonly seen
nowadays this will often subject white
to some really quick pressure against
the d4 point we do have that with c5 and
if white tries to maintain it you can be
sure both Knights and the Queen will
target that point so there can be some
really quick pressure there and that
could be difficult to maintain white
says you know what I don't want to deal
with any of that I'm just gonna give
that pawn up I'm gonna take away from
the center so white won't have to
babysit d4 what's the downside with this
capture well black now has acquired a
two-to-one majority in the center
something that black can look to now
build on
okay let's get some more moves in here
black tracks the pawn back down and from
here we have Knight to e7 this is one of
the top moves and it's a matter of taste
black can go forward with f6 this is
really the variation I had in mind when
I said black and try to build on this
idea of the central majority f6 pretty
much will grant black eight two to zero
majority in the center it's not without
its drawbacks it does create some
weaknesses in the center the e6 square
in the kingside but okay a matter of
taste this is maybe one of the more
testing lines f6 at this moment and even
at a another moment a few moves down the
road 97 in the game castles knight c6 -
attacker is only one defender let's
develop and defend so that's now secured
a lot of attention here this is another
moment for the f6 move and maybe even a
bit more appealing at this moment now
that the bishop is on f4 because should
the F file open up and it would with f6
there will be a valuable tempo gained
against the bishop and it could really
tie in well with the Bishop on c5 anyhow
in this game is Queen c7 black's going
with some piece play more pressure
against 'if I've now three attackers and
only two defenders white does not need
to defend it directly however white has
tactical ideas in mind
white deploys the Knight to c3 so what
would be the issue with capturing this
pawn black doesn't in this game black
plays the best move a6 securing the the
b5 square but this is a nice let me just
kind of fast forward if black was greedy
see a lot of players maybe be greedy
here capturing on e5 what would be the
continuation if black was trying to win
the knight or excuse me win the pawn on
e5 feel free to pause the video
okay this would be the continuation the
best continuation the one that I didn't
see initially I saw a different kind of
tactic I'll share with you but this
would be the killer one-night b5 Queen
has to move and still defend the night
and now the star move one that I found
for I believe on the black and a couple
times at least in blitz clean the h5
this is a nice this one has some nice
geometry hitting the night along a rank
and most importantly pinning the pond to
the king which means f6 is not available
to lend support to the knight this is a
cool one and the bishop isn't around to
lend some support the knight negates it
and while the Knights going down next
the pinned piece is a goner so a nice
sequence there with the Queen to h5 move
and well here's the tactic that I noted
not Knight b5 and Queen h5 but I this is
the one I saw Knight takes d5 and if the
pawn captures this file is open now you
could take the knight and there's no
fear of this because of a pin so a
couple cool mil game tactics should you
find an opponent here on the black end
greedy working themselves into a pin
okay not in this game a six rook e1
three attackers three defenders this
does leave white a little bit vulnerable
on f2 and there's also b2 that sensitive
and sure enough black targets both Queen
to b6 from here white safeguards the
more important of the two Queen takes B
to poison pawn is gone how poison is it
well move 12 this is only a twenty six
move game what did reshef ski-doo next
feel free to pause the video okay here
we go
Knight takes d5 you know this is really
going to get at the black King this is
not a winning shot but it's certainly
going to pose well it's gonna place
black in a very difficult spot and have
to find some nice defensive moves not
the easiest thing to do when your King
is under fire
maybe black was thinking about night to
a for you know this is often uh this is
one of the better moves by the engine by
the way Knight to a4 with the fork and
paving the way for c4 cracking open the
position somewhere okay no Knight to a4
here Knight takes d5 what is the idea
exactly we'll see soon enough but first
quick improvement for the rip with tempo
it's now on a half-open file we nee 3
and now the main idea really behind that
sacrifice and that is to push in the
center and get at that king this ensures
that the e-file will be peeled open it
does hit with the fork that's what you
can basically anticipate the e-file will
now opened up will now open up Knight f6
and now how to get it the King move if
our move 16 here I felt my first
impression of White's next move was that
it was a bit slow but then as I looked
at it a bit more I'm like hmm that's uh
yeah really doesn't make some sense here
Bishop to h4 well more than some sense
what is Bishop h4 doing it's looking to
eliminate blacks best piece best
defensive piece for sure the one that
rests right next to the King you know
the rooks and we can't identify those
pieces as good defenders of the King the
Queen she's way out there in left field
yeah white wants to eliminate blacks
best defensive piece from here we have
Knight to be four this is the giant
lemon of the game there is no you know
black has to do something different here
this is this is a losing move the best
move here for black our one of the best
moves is to drop the bishop back
anticipating this capture and trying to
replace it with another piece the
additional benefit behind a move like
Bishop e7 is that the queen is at least
you know has an avenue to return and
defend some squares around the King
okay this important defensive idea was
not found in the game night before I
could see why I move like that maybe
played you know the bishop is a pretty
strong piece black wants to knock it out
but you know first things first this
square is now provided to the f3 Knight
pounces right in the center with a Czech
King f8
and now Bishop takes Knight that was the
idea behind the Bishop move and the idea
behind the knight move was to take the
bishop on d3 so just swinging the bat
completely around there goes the white
Bishop white says I'm going to rip the
heart out of your structure no G pawn
and the king will never find safety I
don't know if you were maybe thinking
that the king it was possible for the
King to be safe in this position but
without the Jeep on yeah good luck okay
King takes and another pop-quiz move 20
what did reshef ski-doo next this is
probably the star move of the game feel
free to pause the video okay you ready
rook takes b7 this is a wonderful shot
if you did not spot this move how could
you have you have to see that this
Bishop on c8 is overloaded it has two
very important jobs defend b7 and Queen
g4 notice when this bishop played to h4
to take out the knight
what squares was that Knight controlling
what key squares g4 and h5 and sure
enough white is trying to make use of
those squares this is a devastating
tactic rook takes b7 so much so that
black cannot lie cannot take the rook
that it would lead capturing here would
lead to a checkmate in six let me
highlight with this variation as Queen
g4 notice the nice squares the knight
would have under control and can
coordinate with the Queen if the Queen
ever gets here here with the King
anywhere around these squares that's
going to be bad news for Team black
just look at a couple quick variations
if King age six that would be painful
it's one of the painful lines and
another one is let's say king of six
queen no.3
and let's say he goes here well he got
the Queen sweeps in pick your favorite
square King doesn't matter
mayn't next okay yeah this Queen g4 move
is pretty devastating especially with
the knight right there in blacks house
so let's try Dazz Bishop e7 here comes
the Queen there's a lot of stuff hanging
both rooks are hanging but it doesn't it
doesn't matter so this this is a very
serious threat Queen - Queen f7 so as an
example if let's say Knight takes rook
Queen f7 King h6 rook b6 this attack is
just way too much Queen has to now give
herself up as otherwise if King here at
four and then how's that look at that
little path with the rook anyhow big
trouble for team black if this rook is
captured what is tried is rook f8 no
Queen f7 and now okay why not another
pop quiz your way what did white play
next feel free to pause the video okay
here we go
Queen g5 taking advantage of the pin the
king is forced to the corner and now oh
well I'm sorry there's just a lot of
star moves here there's another one on
this move 23 be quick about it
hit that pause button if you'd like here
we go Knight g6 check throwing another
piece right in there white wants out
that King chipping away at this pawn
it's no longer around Queen h6 check
Queen takes g6 check and finally
rook takes Bishop rook b takes bishop
yeah this is this is one way you could
go wrong right whoa hang on there would
be a back rank issue white would get
mated yeah rook B takes a seven and
black at this stage throws in the towel
there's no good defense to the mate
threats on g7 and h7
Queen takes rook rook takes and yeah
this is all that black can do may next a
very flashy game for sure out of this
French defense by Samuel Reshevsky
six-time United States champ feel free
as usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below hope
you enjoyed it and maybe even took a
thing or two away from it that's all for
now take care bye
you